[Music]
so the trump organization when donald
trump left the white house was in rough
shape you know they had just taken a
beating during the pandemic hotels had
closed they had to fire
over 2 400 workers from their business
on top of that they were dealing with
fallout from january 6th
[Music]
[Applause]
so some banks and other real estate
firms said that they no longer wanted to
do anything with the trump organizations
that figure out how to manage that
and then on top of that they were also
contending with an investigation from
the manhattan district attorney who was
just months away with from charging them
with a series of financial crimes
so all of this stuff was building up at
once and you had a lot of outsiders
looking at this picture
and saying basically this is a tower
that's about to collapse and donald
trump is gonna be left there with a
bunch of rubble
and
nothing
[Music]
so in reality donald trump is fine he
got through this period he's gotten
through difficult periods before and
he's done it again
basically what he did was he refinanced
four of his properties allowing him to
suck a lot of cash out of some of those
properties he paid down the loans on
another four of his properties handling
the debt there and then maybe most
critically he sold one of his big money
losers
the trump hotel in washington dc this
had been a property that got a lot of
attention looked like he was making a
lot of money in fact was losing millions
of dollars a year
and donald trump not only got rid of it
by selling it but sold it for an
enormous amount of money far more than
anybody really thought that it was worth
and at the end of the day
he has a cleaned up balance sheet you
know he's sitting on an estimated 375
million dollars of cash
he still has a significant amount of
debt but he's kicked the can down the
road now those loans aren't due for
years and he's going to get through this
just fine
so basically for a real estate
billionaire like donald trump you're
allowed to refinance you know whenever
you want but
unlike sort of in the political world
where you have investigators or perhaps
you know prosecutors looking at your
conduct and saying what you can't and
can't do
in this case it's banks who are playing
that role so banks are going to decide
whether or not they're going to lend to
you again the tricky thing for trump is
that after january 6 a lot of banks said
that they wanted nothing to do with
donald trump but of course if there's
one rule that we know about wall street
is there's always more people looking to
make money so if certain banks say hey
we don't want to work with this guy
other banks are going to say that's what
a great opportunity business just fell
into our lab and so they're going to
look at what his profile is and say okay
what are the value of these assets how
much income are these assets throwing
off and then how much of a complication
is it that this company the trump
organization is under indictment
actively right now and ultimately uh
several lenders came to the conclusion
that those weren't things that they
really had to worry too much about and
that they would lend him money anyways
because they thought that he would be
able to repay those debts and also pay
interest on top of it and in doing so
they would make a significant amount of
money for their banks
steven roth and donald trump have known
each other for years their relationship
goes back decades but for about the last
12 or 15 years they've been business
partners and their business partners on
two
sort of anonymous boring but big big
money-making buildings one in san
francisco one in new york city uh the
one in san francisco is called 555
california street the one in new york
city is called 1290 avenue the americas
the interesting thing
with trump's debt situation is that he
had a lot of equity
locked up in those two buildings but
because vornado owned 70 of the
buildings and trump only had 30 percent
of the buildings he wasn't actually in
full control about whether or not he
could access that equity whether or not
they would sell the things or whether
they would refinance it in such a way
that would allow him to pull cash out
but ultimately steven roth did him a
favor they refinanced 555 california
street and replaced the loan that had
533 million dollars of debt on it with
one that had 1.2 billion
that allowed the two partners to suck
out more than 600 million dollars of
cash uh trump himself you know collected
roughly 150 million dollars of cash from
that refinance
and then they also refinanced 1290
avenue in the americas replacing a 950
million dollar loan with one of the same
size so the end effect is that donald
trump has both of those loans now pushed
out until about 2028 and he's got a
whole lot more cash sitting on his
balance sheet in the meantime that he
could then deploy in other parts of his
business
[Music]
the trump hotel in washington dc was a
big problem from the start trump
organization said that it was going to
invest 200 million dollars into fixing
up the building turning it into a luxury
hotel and in exchange for doing that
they would get the right to then lease
the building from the federal government
which would mean that they had to pay
three million dollars a year to the
federal government in rent and then they
could operate the building as a hotel
but
the building was never set up to make
enough money to cover the interest on
the debt that they used to spend 200
million dollars there or the amount of
rent that they had to cover
with the federal government so
ultimately what ended up happening is
that the building just lost money for
years so amidst all of this the trumps
kind of came up with this crazy plan
which is hey why don't we sell this
money losing hotel for like a wild
amount of money you know the rumor came
out that they would be willing to accept
something in the ballpark of like a half
a billion dollars now at the time you
know most independent people thought
that it was worth somewhere between like
200 maybe 250 million dollars or
something like that and ultimately they
found a buyer who paid a reported 375
million dollars which sounds like a big
discount from 500 million dollars but
when you consider that the place was
actually worth a fraction of that it's a
huge huge amount of money that the trump
organization got to take in and it
allowed them to pay off their deutsche
bank debt that 170 million dollars that
they had borrowed to renovate the
building and it also allowed them to
take a bunch of money into their own
pockets at the end of the day
donald trump for years was able to rely
on deutsche bank they were
a really close lender of his he started
using them back in the 1990s continued
using them up until recent times
his active loans that he had with
deutsche bank one in chicago one in
miami one in dc were against some of his
most troubled properties but deutsche
bank gave him the money anyway and it
really allowed him some flexibility to
do things that he wouldn't necessarily
have been able to do had he not had a
lender who was so agreeable
deutsche bank after january 6
spread the word that they didn't want
anything to do with donald trump so all
of a sudden you have this question of
well who's going to pick up the slack
these deutsche bank loans are coming due
is he going to be able to pay this stuff
out of pocket or is he going to be able
to refinance what ended up happening is
instep the small internet-based bank
that's based out of san diego
called axos bank this is not a bank that
most people have heard of it's not a
bank that historically has done a lot of
big deals but they have done some big
deals with donald trump recently first
they refinanced trump power giving the
president a hundred million dollars
there to repay a previous loan that he
had coming due and secondly they
refinanced doral which is a golf resort
down in miami
again giving them 125 million dollars so
you could pay off
deutsche bank and continue operating
they also had an interesting involvement
in the dc hotel where they took part of
the
interest in the debt that went toward
paying for that 375 million dollar
purchase price so in three of these
deals this small unheard of bank called
access pops up and what it leaves you
with the impression is that donald trump
has found his replacement for deutsche
bank
so donald trump still has plenty of debt
he has an estimated 1.1 billion dollars
debt now remember he also has
significant assets so it's not like he's
broke or anything like that
but he does have a lot of debt that
ultimately he's going to have to pay
back the beauty of what he's done with
his restructuring is he's given himself
a lot of flexibility so now he has an
estimated 375 million dollars of cash on
his balance sheet
if people aren't going to allow him to
refinance some other loans he can now
pay more of them back he also could
theoretically just refinance again he
could of course screw it up i mean he
could you know go do something that is
you know really ambitious project that
he doesn't necessarily have money for
and all of a sudden he could be in a
tight pinch again but right now he's
sort of sitting pretty
[Music]
you